la bête ça fait plusieurs saisons que
vous faites partie de la bande voilà on
adore vos anecdotes et sont devenus
légendaires maintenant les connais un
petit peu par coeur et on les aime comme
ça et puisque vous rappeler comment vous
avez été recruté ou oui moi aussi
j'étais plus femme et moi je vous
connaissais de rtl oui et moi je vous
suivez dans les émissions je vous adorez
dans le grand concours on l'a fait
plusieurs fois ensemble vous avez gagné
pas moi et c'était moi je vous ai
toujours vraiment admiré en tant
qu'animateur y compris quand vous et le
bêtisier ouais ouais quand même voie
bassi parce que vous aviez justement une
façon de personnaliser le truc et vous
m'avez dit à rtl tient un jour on
bossera ensemble et vous m'avez dit ce
que tu serais d'accord pour me rejoindre
je dis oui et après vous avez croisé
dans la rue quand l'émission s'est monté
vous me dit est ce que vous pouvez
toujours d'accord pour nous rejoindre
j'ai dit oui qu'après plus de plus
d'appels du tout comme vous aviez plein
de gens brillants je me suis dit bon bah
il a oublié un comme moi je pense pas
que le monde m'attend et en revenant
chez ricoh et tu voulais absolument je
bosse avec lui et lui ils étaient tous
les jours devant elle en disant je
rejoins nous sur les réseaux sociaux
comme tu es nul ça va être drôle et
finalement je suis allé à france 4 avec
lui quand vous vous en étiez parti vous
m'avez dit ceux qui songent avec cauet
ne viendront jamais dans l'émotion à
cauet qui présentait l'émission
non c'est pas lui provisy trône alaouite
et puis vous avez dit me viendrait
jamais dans l'émission puisque justice
jusqu'à alors vous avez une défection et
quelqu'un m'a appelé en disant ce que tu
serais d'accord jour des chèques notre
devenir
égérie ben moi oui moi j'adore toujours
cyril donc et c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé je vous ai plus lâché aviez
besoin d'une gamme donc non c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai regardez une petite
compil isabelle morini-bosc regarder une
à une à côté alors je peux vous dire
elle est à la tête parce que c'est vrai
et mine de rien c'est le magazine ne
plus tirer le pitch american pie non
mais c'est vrai et oui physiquement
puisque moi ça c'est sûr ça courait
alors et isabelle chien boullier
regardez isabelle n'a pas changé on a
fait le forcing sur isabelle la passion
le lien il corinne charby là c'est la
même
c'est la même aujourd'hui